[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
en collaboration avec l'université des
verts qui vous le savez a lieu cette
semaine et nous allons aborder un sujet
tout à fait passionnant celui des
nouvelles démocratie locale
vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup de
phénomènes qui sont censées répondre à
la crise de la démocratie on voit
beaucoup de commissions au plan national
la commission sur le climat par exemple
mais cette démocratie ces nouvelles
formes de démocratie cette démocratie
participative cette autre acide direct
on verra comment il faut la nommer elle
fonctionne sans doute beaucoup mieux au
niveau local et nous allons parler
aujourd'hui avec mes invités camille
morio bonjour bonjour nous est maîtresse
de conférences à sciences po saint
germain et vous êtes l'auteur d'un livre
formidable sur ce sujet qui est le guide
pratique de la démocratie participative
locale ccc berger levrault luc chatel
bonjour vous êtes le maire de bougival
du chef de vision de versailles grand
parc et dans votre nom votre ville
bruges ivan vous avez depuis 2000 14
depuis votre élection en 2014 montait
beaucoup d'expérience de démocratie
participative on va évidemment parler
stéphane becker bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le fondateur et le président de la
plateforme goûteur de cette plateforme
cofondateur cofondateur et président un
essai d'une plateforme qui évidemment
est très utilisée pour ses expériences
et expérimentations et cette vie de la
démocratie locale de la démocratie
participative locale et fabrizzio livini
bonjour vous êtes sociologue vous êtes
enseignera sciences po saint germain et
vous êtes spécialiste de ce qu'on
appelle on va
on va définir les termes peut un peu
mais ce qu'on appelle les civic tech
alors on va peut-être pour commencer
essayer de définir savoir exactement de
quoi on parle
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des
expressions très différentes on parle de
démocratie directe de démocratie semi
directe de démocratie délibérative de
démocratie participative
camille meuriot est-ce qu'il faut
distinguer entre autres ces termes ou
est-ce que ils nous disent à peu près
les mêmes formes de démocratie
ça fait déjà beaucoup de choses à
définir le tout je pense qu'il faut
aussi rappeler le concept de démocratie
représentative qui est tellement riche
en revanche en parla vous avez raison
c'est un régime où les décisions
publiques sont prises par les élus
en fait démocratie directe semis direct
délibérative et participative ça se
raccrochent plus ou moins à une idée
commune qui est celle selon laquelle les
citoyens doivent pouvoir intervenir dans
la prise de décision publique en dehors
des élections
ensuite il ya des variations entre les
différents concepts la démocratie
directe démocratie semi directe et la
démocratie participative
ça met plutôt en avant la force que la
participation citoyenne peut avoir dans
la prise de décision au public
typiquement la démocratie directe c'est
comment les citoyens on prend
directement des décisions sans passer
par les élus la démocratie semi directe
c'est une démocratie représentative
classique avec des élus mais dans
laquelle on va injecter quelques outils
de démocratie directe c'est un peu ce
qu'on a en france au niveau national
avec les élections et le référendum
et puis vous avez la démocratie
participative qui recouvre tous les
dispositifs qui permet de demander leur
avis aux citoyens sans que ça n'engage
les élus par exemple il ya des conseils
de quartier les consultations locales
etc
mais la démocratie participative elle
peut aussi s'entendre au sens large de
tout ce qui permet globalement citoyen
d'intervenir dans la décision publique
en dehors des élections avec ce sens un
peu plus extensifs on voit que ça
recouvre un peu les autres concepts
convient d'évoquer en conte dernier il
ya le concept de démocratie
liberati fille un peu à part parce que
il ne dit rien de la force que la
participation citoyenne peut avoir en
fait c'est un concept qui se focalise
plutôt sur la manière dont on prend les
décisions
puisque dans cette approche une décision
n'est bonne que si elle est issue d'un
échange d'arguments d'une discussion
entre différentes personnes qui peut qui
peut d'ailleurs être un espion avec des
élus et dans toutes ses formes que vous
n'êtes d'écrire celle qui est la plus
utilisée notamment au niveau local c'est
pour dire que c'est la démocratie
participative c'est plutôt celle là
effectivement en plus d'outils qui
consiste à demander la parole aux
citoyens pour compléter donner des
éléments supplémentaires d'information à
aux élus qui vont in fine et prendre la
décision
fabrizzio libye ni est ce que on sait
qu'il ya une crise de la démocratie on
l'a vu avec plusieurs événements il est
jaune voit pas revenir même sur tous les
événements récents
est ce que justement ce recours à des
nouvelles formes de démocratie c'est
c'est une façon d'aider cette démocratie
à redevenir ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
n'est peut-être plus ou alors est-ce que
c'est le constat de cette crise d'une
crise majeure de la démocratie oui
certainement il faut restituer toutes
les expériences de démocratie directe
participative et délibérative des
dernières années dans cette crise de la
démocratie après pour répondre à vos
questions en direct c'est à dire est-ce
que ça modifie réellement la démocratie
représentative sarah corrige ça la salle
intègre la complémentaire à celle
independent et des expériences en fait
singulière et du cou enfin si un peu le
chantier de deux chercheurs comme comme
comme nous mêmes c'est à dire exactement
d'allez aller voir un peu et de faire
des études aussi comparative entre des
expériences locales
et nationales ou c'est genre d'outils
sont implémentés donc et je pense que
pour répondre à cette question il faut
avoir une approche en quelques sortes
multidimensionnelle parce qu'il faut
regarder à plusieurs niveaux à la fois à
la fois la philosophie politique en
quelque sorte de des porteurs et aussi
des usagers des plateformes décédé outil
à la fois le design de plateforme
elle-même est aussi les infrastructures
je donne un exemple pour chaque ci j'ai
donc la fille de sophie politique par
exemple pour le mouvement 5 étoiles à
l'italie qui est un essai force
politique qui utilise une plateforme qui
s'appelle rousseau on parle plutôt de
parlementarisme direct 20 18 exemple à
barcelone où la mer à dakola ou a aussi
une plateforme qui s'appelle décide in
qatar ça veut dire
nous décidons elle s'inscrit plutôt dans
le municipal isme libertaire
c'est-à-dire un courant de l'anarchisme
donc c'est pas du tout les mêmes
philosophies politiques ce qui amène
effectivement à des implémentations très
différente peu pareil
c'est là se voit se constate dans le
design de la plateforme dans lequel par
exemple
enfin par exemple la plateforme ruisseau
des cinq étoiles la délibération est
très limité le il ya un rapport à celle
verticale entre l'élu qui met en ligne
le texte de la loi et les inscrits qui
commentent en quelque sorte sans pouvoir
se commenter entre eux et sans pouvoir
dire avec les par contre barcelone la
délibération le design de la plateforme
à permet une délibération beaucoup plus
approfondie les inscrits pouvant
proposer des projets proposer des
modifications ces projets pouvant aussi
proposé des commentaires aux
modifications de ses projets
donc la capacité de délibération par
design la plateforme est plus grand et
puis dernier dernièrement les
infrastructures un des grands problèmes
d'éthique expérience si aussi à qui
appartiennent les plateformes donc les
serveurs pardon donc si amazon ou plutôt
la mairie et bah ça change book bin on
en parle dans quelques instants avec
stéphane beckham et l'ucm appel ce qui
m'intéresserait vous êtes maire depuis
2014 de bougival et ils vous avez
beaucoup utilisé ces les plateformes la
démocratie participative à quoi
correspondait ce souhait d'utiliser ce
type de démocratie
d'abord ça a commencé par un constat moi
je suis élu depuis 2001 j'étais adjoint
aux finances et pendant deux mandats on
avait l'habitude d'organiser des
réunions d ailleurs public en avant les
élections ça se passait toujours très
bien avec les habitants l'échangé on
avait beaucoup de relations et puis
après il n'y avait plus rien des
réunions publiques existé mais
finalement il n'y avait pas vraiment des
changes ne venait d'une certaine partie
de la population et donc du coup très
vite quand j'étais élu en 2014 je me
suis dit faut absolument qu'on arrive à
créer un lien permanent avec avec nos
habitants et de pouvoir échanger
échanger sur les projets mais aussi
écouter sur ce que ce que les bulls est
belle et avait à nous dire et donc à
partir de là j'ai cherché ce qui pouvait
nous aider à mettre en place ce type de
relation et c'est une application donc
qui s'appelle goûteurs qui qui démarrait
à l'époque si nous a permis déjà de
démarrer de démarrer cette nouvelle
forme de relation avec
la population d'avoir des réponses
ouvertes ou fermées aux questions qu'on
pouvait poser de cibler les questions
sur les quartiers de de faire passer de
l'information d'avoir des retours sur
sur des actions et mais tout en
précisant bien que pour nous il s'agit
de démocratie participative donc un
outil de des chances de et de dead à la
construction des projets mais il n'a
jamais été question par exemple de
d'outils de référendum local et je
termine en disant que le pacte implicite
qu'on a passés avec les bougies donner
c'est que bien sûr nous nous tenons
compte de leur avis a été rendu public
et il est disponible pour tout
utilisateur de l'application mais bien
sûr la décision ultime reste au conseil
municipal
oui c'est vous qui prenez fillon ont une
fille dès l'âge la décision ça vous
arrive d'ailleurs de prendre des
décisions qui sont opposés aux souhaits
finalement de la population que vous
avez consulté
non non en réalité ça ne nous est jamais
arrivé
tant mieux tant mieux quand même mais
c'est vrai que et l'accueil de la
population parce que je me souviens que
les premières expériences
c'était vieux c'était à grenoble c'était
monsieur du vaudou qui était qui était
maire qui avait fait les premiers
conseils de quartier il est je me
souviens qu'il vous raconter qu'ils me
couper l'électricité dans les quartiers
pour que les habitants viennent disent
qu'on paie donc bon on a fait des
précédents des années 70 des programmes
depuis comment été l'accueil de la
population à ce qu'elle était surprise
au départ oui les dents tout à fait tout
à fait surprise au départ et mai
je dirais positivement surprise parce
que nous avons démarré par des
consultations sur des sujets assez ça
sur discuter de est-ce que vous
intéresse que l'on développe l activité
par exemple ils ont commencé à voter à
donner leur avis et on a et on a tenu
compte de leurs avis et à chaque fois on
tient compte de leur avis bien sûr pas
nécessairement en utilisant oui à la
journée pons on est fan on n'est pas à
la barcelonaise où va ce qu'il
délibérations et modifier la mode la
délibération père des amendements etc
mais ça peut éveiller évidemment
influencé le projet sert forme s'en
sortir sa configuration est donc c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé
alors stéphane lesquin parlez nous un
peu de vous taire fabrique du olivine il
nous disait tout à l'heure
oui c'est banal c'est important de tiki
tiki et à qui appartient la plateforme
quand vous avez un goûteur raconté de
gossas 4 et pourquoi voulez vous fondez
au fond vous confondez alors je me
permets de commenter parce qu'elles
aient des points après deux roues ont
été complétés soulevé je trouvais ça
très intéressant je valide en tout ce
qui a été dit non seulement par camille
et fabrizio mais sur le point est ce que
en fait ces outils qui apparaissent et
qui sont pour moi tous singuliers un con
con des différences sur commande de deux
par leur design en fait qu'est ce que ça
nous dit en fait dû peut-être du moment
qu'on est en train de vivre
d'un point de vue réflexion collective
pour pour moi là c'est le citoyen est
aussi l'acteur on va dire des cités qui
parle c'est on est un symptôme d'un
besoin d'un nouveau rapport peut-être à
la décision collective ou la décision
publique
voilà je jusqu'à cette petite erreur en
thèse est alors goûteurs ensuite motors
est né en 2014 comme je disais moi on
est deux avoir fait pareil un constat
comment comment l'expliqué simplement
parce que j'ai pas la même vision
maintenant que je l'avais en 2014 quand
vous l'avez fondé cette histoire quel
réseau voilà alors quand quand je les
fondés en tant que citoyen il me
paraissait assez évident qu'on de compte
devrait déjà avoir ce type d'outil pour
être partie prenante on va dire dans le
processus de décision comme ça c'était
notre point de départ et à partir de là
on s'est dit pas quel type d'outil
comment quel angle aussi puisque pour
rebondir sur ce que disait fera vidyo
fait qu' il existe un très large panel
de solutions et toutes font pas les
mêmes choses et le design va avoir un
impact sur ce qu'on peut faire ou ce
qu'on ne peut pas faire notamment nous
on est pas on n'est pas juste une
plateforme nous notre vocation c'est de
faire participer un maximum de gens de
suture de l'idéation sur la sueur de la
concertation sur sur de la votation si
besoin est donc on est sur smartphone et
et en version web du coup il ya des
complexités d'interaction qu'on ne peut
pas faire
defacto donc donc on a choisi on va dire
ben un processus qui permet d'embarquer
énormément de gens qui sont plutôt loin
on va dire en typologie habituellement
des processus participatif qui l'avons
pouvoir parce que c'est simple parce que
parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui le temps
passé sur smartphone est en train de de
d'augmenter significativement donc
forcément quand on veut faire participer
tout le monde qu'on va avoir une réponse
l'outil d'avoir une réponse sur une
plateforme n'est aussi sur mobile qu'on
veut simplifier qui a pas trop train à
la participation ne soit pas en gros une
usine à gaz
forcément on va devoir faire des choix
de design pour que ce soit le plus
inclusif possible
voilà du coup j'ai oublié votre question
non mais c'était c'était les raisons
pour lesquelles vous aviez font des
voûtains et et vous nous lisez bien bien
expliqué et justement la problématique
est peut-être fabrizzio les vinyles là
dessus c'est intéressant
c'est vrai que c'est il ya le recours à
ces plateformes le recours à ces
nouvelles technologies
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque dans
cette nouvelle forme de démocratie
d'accroître la fracture numérique c'est
à dire que est ce que est ce que est ce
qu'on sait d'ailleurs est ce que ce sont
plutôt des jeunes qui participent à ce
genre de consultation que des personnes
âgées ou est-ce que c'est assez bien
répartis
pas forcément pas forcément en fait à
les y aller les hippies mais pas
forcément ça dépend par exemple il ya
des études qui ont montré que les coups
de fil mais que l'une des premières de
ces plateformes qui avaient été portées
1 disons well fonction d une part d par
les partis pirates européens en fait ont
montré que des études ont montré que en
italie par exemple au début la
population qui participait le plus
c'était plutôt des hommes blancs
effectivement un bac + plus est est
plutôt entre 30 et 40 ans donc c'est pas
forcément c'est pas forcément la
population la plus jeune mais encore une
fois ça dépend des contextes locaux et
ensuite bien sûr vous vous dites très
très bien par rapport à la fracture
numérique
disons que les civic tech donc
certainement que juju emploi pas
vraiment milan peut lire et venir si
vous voulez il fait d'ici ou d'ailleurs
ce que cdc vittek puisque voilà c'est
pendant que
beaucoup de gens ne connaissent pas ok
c'est lyon 2 essayons de donner une
définition
oui donc en fête civique takraw
technologie civique
en fait c'est un terme qui est à deux
problèmes de d'une part on ne sait pas
exactement ce que ce que ça veut dire
parce que parfois les technologies elle
même parfois les porteurs de ces
technologies
et puis ensuite c'est un terme qui a été
beaucoup réapproprier par des
expériences marchande en fait et donc il
a eu il a été très très utilisé et ces
dernières années mais une collègue qui
fait sa thèse sur le cv tech est qui et
qui ne l'a pas encore terminé ma malle
m'a dit que effectivement les les
acteurs surtout non marchand tendent à
l'utiliser dès - à - moi parce que
personnellement dans mes travaux
j'utilise plate forme d'éducation ou à
la 16eme des termes plus plus neutre qui
évite de prendre voilà non plus et
français oui oui oui on peut un peu
traduire la technologie si vite mais le
problème le bol le bref qu'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
thermique delà du risque de fracture se
de fracture numérique quoi en fait on
observe ce que je dis c'est que les
tictacs souffre en fait face à ce crime
de la même société dans laquelle
s'inscrivent les algorithmes des lacets
des combats voilà donc c'est pas
quelqu'un comme d'hab d'un d'un couteau
les acteurs et surtout cantonné
chercheurs il faut pas tomber dans ce
qu'on appelle c'est un grand moment mais
je vais l'expliquer le déterminisme
technologique c'est à dire l'idée un peu
naïve
ne pensez que une technologie suffit à
elle-même pour changer toute la société
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche il ya
des avoirs plex entre la technique et la
société et donc aussi des influences
réciproques et on observe pour les civic
tech comme pour les algorithmes
marchant un tuteur légal général
on observe en fait une parfois une ré
production des inégalités déjà
existantes en quelque sorte dans la
société est bon j'ai envie de dire que
pour palier à ces inégalités il faudrait
des réformes politiques qui vont bien au
delà de la réforme purement
institutionnels ou purement technique
donc voila et et je peux ajouter que
certains de ses acteurs par exemple par
exemple à barcelone essaye de
effectivement pallier un peu à cette
facilitant l'accès à désirade et à des à
des ordinateurs publics à internet
publics partout dans la ville pour
essayé d'inclure les populations si les
plus dévastées favorise s'évade mais
qu'elle nous interroger mais luc chatel
c'est une des questions que forcément
vous êtes vous et qui participent à ces
consultations
bien sûr et justement nous avons
beaucoup évolué au cours de ces de ces
cinq années 5 6 années nous sommes
maintenant à 720,7 120 personnes donc
grosso modo on a neuf mille habitants si
on exclut les moines vivifiant les plus
de 70 ans selman traditionnellement peu
enclins à utiliser ses outils ça
représente à peu près 15 % de la
population si le rêve pas rien ça c'est
déjà intéressant de réponse est dans les
22 et quand on regarde la structure de
ses sept cent vingt autres personnes
nous avons entre on et j'ai même vous
dire précisément les chiffres que ça
représente
les 25 30 ans ça représente 6 % de ces
de ses 720 membres les 35-45 ans 19% les
45 55 21 % les 55-65 12% l'envoyer ray
on voit bien reste intéressant ça c'est
très intéressant parce que justement on
a une répartition après les 65 75 9
pour cent et les plus de 75 ans 4% bien
on a une répartition qui est quand même
assez assez intéressant parce qu'on
rouvre a finalement touché glane
majoritairement ceux qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
de de pouvoir de pouvoir pour paqueter
pendant un an toutes amendes à ceux qui
venaient pas aux réunions publiques ce
qui était relativement accents des
grands événements locaux et du coup avec
cette répartition donc sachant qu'au
début on avait peut-être une population
un peu plus peu plus concentré que comme
les effets spéciaux sur sur les bacs + +
30 40 et c'est maintenant on voit bien
qu'on a une assise qui est plus large et
qui est plus intéressante
stéphane dès qu'un jour vous livre
dirhams aussi justement sur le risque de
sept fractures dues à l'utilisation à la
de nouvelles technologies ouais je vais
compléter parce qu'il ya souvent un
discours qu'on entend par me on va dire
les acteurs dont et des technologies
cilic un pareil gelé les étiquettes
c'est toujours réducteur mais bon on
quoi nous chez shelter on pense que en
fait un outil évidemment seul ne sert
pas à grand chose comme un outil il est
au service d'une politique il au service
d'une démarche et il s'inscrit dans une
complémentarité
c'est ce qu'on l'a on prenait un exemple
à barcelone mais quoi d'autre dans
chaque collectivité avec lesquels on
fonctionne veulent toujours y avoir des
points ou un personnel que ce soit
l'accueil d'une mairie ou à la
bibliothèque municipale
on importe qui va pouvoir venir se faire
former s'il est si les pays qui paie par
exemple ou s'il veut participer
voilà donc va y avoir une multitude de
deux points d'entrée et évidemment ça ne
remplace pas d'aider d'autres processus
qui se sont la réunion publique
ça va venir en complément en fait voilà
donc cesser la multitude des démarches
qui va faire aboutir sur quelque chose
de plus participative de plus de plus
riches en fait foi la commune mais yoann
je vous poser deux questions une un peu
historique et l'autre plus que plus
juridique l'apparition de justement de
cette nouvelle forme de démocratie
participative locale
est-ce qu'elles découlent alors ça c'est
la question un peu historique des lois
de la décentralisation
parce qu'elles sont liées aux lois de
décentralisation c'est vrai que les
textes sur la démocratie participative
se sont plutôt une typique et après
l'intervention de la décentralisation en
et puis la décentralisation repose sur
l'idée politique selon laquelle les
territoires et donc les populations sont
les plus légitimes à prendre les
décisions qui les concernent donc on
pourrait dire que a priori dans
l'abstrait la décentralisation est
plutôt favorable à la démocratie
participative
mais ce que l'on observe c'est que
l'endroit est bien le cadre juridique
laisse clairement la main aux élus chien
en matière de prise de décision publique
au niveau local est d'ailleurs notre
constitution qui est le texte je vais
dit que le plus fort de notre ordre
juridique dit bien que les collectivités
territoriales s'administrent librement
par des conseils élus et encore plus
loin dans le raisonnement certains
mobilise même ce principe de libre
administration des collectivités pour
s'opposer à toute norme juridique qui en
poserait de donner la parole aux
habitants donc c'est une certaine
interprétation de la décentralisation
fort et enfin pardon excusez moi je vous
en prie non mais j'allais dire que au
contraire il ya
série d' entités locales qui n'ont pas
en tant attendu ni la décentralisation
ni le droit d'ailleurs pour faire la
démocratie participative et encore
aujourd'hui il ya de nombreuses
initiatives qui se tiennent en dehors du
cadre juridique souvent justement parce
que ce cadre juridique est trop
restrictif et puis faut pas oublier que
la côte est du droit de la
décentralisation il ya droit de
l'environnement et le droit de
l'urbanisme qui ont apporté beaucoup en
matière de démocratie participative avec
les débats publics les concertations
préalables ainsi chez ton je dirais que
il ya un espèce de lien d'opportunités
qui existe théoriquement entre
décentralisation et démocratie
participative mais que la
décentralisation n'entraîne pas
nécessairement de la démocratie
participative et alors je regarde ce que
vous disiez au fond le grand principe
qui domine toutes ses formes de
démocratie c'est quand même un principe
de liberté tôt qu'on n'attende pas au
fond principes fondamentaux de la
constitution
on a le droit d'utiliser tous plaie en
route toutes les techniques démocratique
cocon souhaite mettre en place des
dispositifs qui reste consultatif c'est
à dire des dispositifs qui ne vont pas
engagé juridiquement les élus donc je
pense à la consultation locale qu'on
peut aussi appeler référendum
consultatif mais je dirais qu'il ya deux
grandes limites sur les dispositifs
qu'on peut mettre en place d'abord il ya
le respect des droits fondamentaux en
typiquement ne peut pas discriminer une
catégorie de population en mettant en
place un dispositif participatif bien
sûr et puis il ya l'idée que les
autorités administratives donc notamment
les collectivités territoriales commune
département région etc n'ont pas le
droit de se défaire de leur pouvoir de
décision
c'est un principe général de droit
administratif
c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas le
droit en tant que collectivité de mettre
en place un outil dans quel citoyen
prendrait directement la décision
il faut qu'ils en texte qui vous y
autorise et ces textes là sont quasiment
inexistants bon c'est vrai
non non c'est non ce n'est pour fixer en
effet oui ce cadre c'est important de
savoir est ce que les gars les et alors
on retrouve dans votre livre un
évidemment les cadres juridiques de ces
différentes formes de démocratie mais
est ce qu est ce qu on assiste à des
expériences comme ça qu'ils ont été
exclus du contentieux par exemple sur
des expériences démocratie participative
oui on a eu un bienvenue plusieurs on
peut en citer un récent qui est à la
ville de grenoble qui a essayé de mettre
en place ce qui se tape les endroits
d'interpellation des élus par les
citoyens d'interpellations citoyenne
l'idée était de permettre à deux milles
habitants de 16 ans et plus de saisir le
conseil municipal d'une question la
question devait être discutée en conseil
municipal qui devait se prononcer et
soit le conseil municipal adoptait la
proposition soit il s'y opposer et dans
ce cas là on organiser une votation
citoyenne à la caq pouvez participer
tous les habitants à partir de 16 ans
également et si vous atteignez un
certain nombre de votes positifs et bien
la mairie s'engager à suivre la décision
même si elle n'était pas conforme à au
projet politique porté par la majorité
municipale est ce dispositif là
d'interpellations citoyenne a été
annulée en justice devant le juge
administratif
oui ça ne correspond pas aux principes
de la de l'exercice de démocratie dans
la république c'est ça au fond y avait
plusieurs choses qui faisait problème
notamment ce fameux principe on n'a pas
le droit de se défaire 6 voire de 10,6
voilà c'est ça une même de la révocation
des élus enfin le teaser alors on va on
va essayer maintenant de voir quelles
sont les formes de cette nouvelle
démocratie locale et justement avec les
expériences qui ont été menées notamment
à bougival
[Musique]
alors il s'appelle justement à l'eau
concrètement parce que j'ai vu que dans
les consultations sur une monnier ya
évidemment des choses très concrètes
mais ça va presque jusqu'au bout au
dépôt ce aux dépens selon munich est ce
que est ce que c'était un cheminement un
peu long comme ça que vous avez commencé
par des souches très concrète ou très
pratique vous très quotidienne et vous
êtes allé plus loin où quand comment ça
s'est passé et quelles sont les grands
domaines où fonds dans lesquels vous
vous consulter la population
alors déjà faut bien cadrée de quoi on
parle à ce que le budget municipal gc
commun c'est nous d'abord et il répond à
des compétences obligatoires
le mileu vont exercer que nous devons
mettre en place et des compétences
facultatives mais si je dirais qu'à peu
près 60% notre budget c'est s'applique
aux cons pressante aux compétences
obligatoires et ce qui est obligatoire
est obligatoire de reprendre on ne va
pas mettre cela au vote mis à décision
citoyenne et sur les 40% que reste-t-il
il reste des compétences facultatives
que sur lesquels chacun peut se
prononcer mais en réalité c'est pas tout
à fait et c'est pas tout à fait vrai
puisque dans ses compétences
facultatives vous avez par exemple la
cantine la cantine scolaire n'est pas
une obligation mais dans nos usages
c'est quand même une obligation va
pouvoir
on va pouvoir par exemple faire une
consultation sur est ce que on va
proposer à nos enfants des menus bio à
50 pour cent soixante-quinze pour cent
ou cent pour cent mais ça demandera
savoir un coût supplémentaire qui vont
partager ou pas partager donc là on peut
effectivement rentré dans quelque chose
qui va impliquer une catégorie de
population et sur les quais qui va nous
aider à prendre la décision de faire ou
de ou de ne pas faire pour une fois
c'est un outil d'aidé à la décision on
est dans la démocratie participative
vous avez les dents dans des compétences
facultatives vous avez par exemple la
création de berceau de deux crèches
bon ben là on va dire que ce n'est pas
obligatoire mais en même temps par
rapport à la structure de la population
par rapport à ce que ce les attentes en
matière de garde d'enfants
eh bien on peut avant là on a le souhait
le désir de consulter la population pour
savoir si nécessaire de créer de
nouveaux persos de en crèche municipale
après c'est toujours difficile puisque
quand vous créez les nouveaux persos
c'est un investissement sur du long
terme prises par a pris par des jets par
des personnes qui à un instant t vont
avoir un besoin particulier donc il nous
avons sept n'ont besoin de prendre des
décisions sur la base de la vie ils sont
donnés par parler par les habitants mais
on doit les remettre à l'aune de deux
bad et des perspectives budgétaires sur
certaines périodes des évolutions de
population tels qu'on peut les anticiper
donc nous avons nous besoin de prévoir
et pour prévoir il faut à un moment
donné bien marquer les choses donc ce
cadre est important de bien définir
parce que on ne peut pas mettre à la
décision
ou au vote citoyen tout ce que tout tout
tout ce qui concerne le budget de la
ville
après nous avons nous avons utilisé le
ce cette plateforme pour interroger la
population sur des sujets extrêmement
extrêmement variées par exemple nous
avons un magazine municipal nous avons
nous avons demandé à la population ce
qui les intéressait ce qui vous
intéresse et pas de façon à avoir un
magazine qui soient le mieux adapté
possible aux besoins de la population
nous avons fait une étude sur les
habitudes de consommation sur le marché
sur les commerces de proximité pour à la
fois comprendre pourquoi nos habitants
avaient l'habitude plutôt d'aller dans
les supermarchés etc
est ce qu'on pouvait faire pour les
attirer un peu plus dans dans nos
commerces
nous avons le cas cet hymne à mon
exemple de d'impact budgétaire
nous avons financé les vélos électriques
avant que la région ile de france ne
fasse bougival est une ville assez
vallonné et pour favoriser le passage de
de la seconde voiture un vélo
nous avons pensé que financer les vélos
électriques pourrait être une bonne une
bonne décision et donc nous avons lancé
une consultation sur sur les vélos
électriques
citation a été très positive et qu'ils
avaient remises de de mettre en place
cette cette participation au financement
du héros écrit nous avons créé une amap
et une ferme urbaine
pour cela nous avons transformé un
ancien terrain de foot dans en zone de
maraîchage
là aussi il est important de comprendre
quelle est elle
l'appétence de 2
de nos habitants à face à un projet très
innovant très ambitieux mais qui
évidemment changer des habitudes
changent et des standards et qu'il qui
était nécessaire de faire valider ou
d'abord d'expliquer que le on a besoin
d'expliquer mais aussi de de faire
valider par par la population et là
aussi le les retours étaient extrêmement
positif vous voyez c'est ce sont des ce
sont des moyens qui permettent de de
valider des intuitions parfois de les
modifier parce que par exemple on avait
pensé lancer un bike park dans dans un
parc forestier puis finalement on s'est
aperçu que il y avait très peu de très
peu de personnes intéressées pour un
investissement très important et donc ça
permettait de bien qualifié le la
décision et de ne pas se resté sur
l'impression d'en donner parce qu'il ya
une ou deux personnes qui sont très
actives liste sur le sujet et de pouvoir
ramener bah oui c'est intéressant mais
pas forcément pas forcément dans
l'intérêt général
est-ce que les vous est ce que dans
l'ensemble par dont elle sait pas si la
question est très clair mais est ce que
les populations des réponses plutôt
éthique je pense par exemple est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à payer plus pour avoir
plus de bio dans les dans les cantines
la réponse a été oui et dans ce cas là
il n'y a pas des gens qui vous dit vu
peu de venir vous dire après tournée
mais moi je n'ai pas déjà pas les moyens
d'avoir des ordinateurs donc j'ai pas pu
répondre à cette question et et ça ne
les ai pas les moyens de payer plus
alors oui oui on peut avoir ce genre de
on peut avoir ce genre de plus de
commentaires maintenant le
mais peut-il et que le ticket à la
cantine et est soumis au quotient
familial et l'examen des impacts sur sur
les catégories les plus et les moins
élevés étaient extrêmement faibles
donc non ce qu'on a fait en réalité et
c'est qu'on leur a dit voilà aujourd'hui
à la cantine on a 1 5 repas par ma 5e
pendant mon âge on rentrait oui celle ci
alors en entrée plat de résistance
fromage et dessert et on a dit ben voilà
plutôt que de d'avoir 4 4 plats on vous
propose d'en avoir que entrée à distance
et fromage ou dessert fuir votre parti
en augmente le pourcentage de bio dans
la sphère internet en voilà et c'est
finalement ça a coûté pour quelques
centimes de plus par part partout des
cantines qui étaient extrêmement faibles
et ça a été et guides très très bien la
nuit
vous voyez c'est son ca entre équipes
d'arbitrage ou tester et ça marche très
bien fonctionné désistement on voit bien
là comment ça marche
ça peut très bien marché au niveau d'une
ville peut être au niveau du département
d'une région c'est à dire quand on est
face à des problèmes concrets
est ce que cette démocratie
participative pour la com ça mais voilà
qualifié autrement on va voir ce que
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
elle l'est aussi
il est possible aussi au plan national
ou plan des grandes décisions politiques
qui sont beaucoup plus éloignés vais
d'abord des citoyens
bonne question c'est c'est un grand
débat qui traverse à la fois la reine
activiste politique à la fois la reine
universitaire il ya dans son dos deux
écoles où je vais s'amplifier mais ceux
qui disent que
tout le pouvoir au local donc il faut
partir du local pouvoir éventuellement
changer aussi le global ou alors se
limiter tout simplement trop local et
d'autres qui disent qu'il faut d'abord
il faut d'abord changer le système
général c'est à dire la constitution en
fait
camille bien expliqué qu'il ya des
limites - bar à barcelone je le vois
aussi c'est à dire que la mairie ne peut
pas tout faire donc parce que il ya un
cadre plus général qui ait sévi de la
constitution donc moi je pense que les
deux dynamiques
enfin si si je dois donner mon opinion
politique pas seulement de chercheurs je
pense que i les deux dynamiques sont
fondamentales et qu'il faut faire les
deux quoi il faut changer de carte
constitutionnel le pouvoir
aussi nous permettre beaucoup plus de
marge de manoeuvre aussi aussi au local
c'était votre routeur le pardon bouteurs
vous l'utilisez plus tôt pour les villes
comme bougival ou es ce que vous avez
participé -déjà- des consultations plus
étendue plus nationale l'outil en tant
que tel il n'a pas de
comment dire de limites intrinsèquement
que que l'audience soit chez pas une
petite collectivité un village de 2 500
personnes
où qu'on soit sur une strate beaucoup
plus grande
on a pu travailler avec des départements
des régions et je rebondis aussi au
moment du débat national quel était le
terme et cahiers de doléances d'aider
des gens utiliser l'outil pour faire
remonter les liens et les idées
citoyennes par exemple donc non pour
rebondir sur ce sur ce que disait favori
tôt mais on est avant tout quand même un
outil de d'initiative locale parce que
parce qu'on sent aussi que c'est là que
ça se passe sur les améliorations on va
dire concrète c'est ce que quand on
parle de chose de très très jédir la
nouvelle ligne de bus l'ailé les projets
ce qu'on appelle l'urbanisme la cantine
concertée à l'heure actuelle et les des
projets d'aménagement on sent dès que
les gens sont impliqués
la petit à petit on n'a pas ce que c'est
un c1 c'est un chemin on va dire la
participation citoyenne c'est parce que
vous avez un outil que du jour au
lendemain les gens se mettent à
participer on les a habitués et
culturellement à ne pas participer donc
pour qu'il redevienne acteurs ça prend
du temps et et et l'angle locale c'est à
dire je vais m'investir sur ce qui me
concerne sur ce qui est très tangibles
et concrets évidemment est plus simple
pour mobiliser après
après une heure ça reste un outil de
concertation digital demain ont proposé
on va de l'idéation à concertation à la
votation on peut poser une question à
n'importe quel strates déchets laissés
par exemple c'est pas je dis est ce
qu'est ce que vous voulez passer au
système d'élection à la proportionnelle
vous pouvez le faire oui théoriquement
courants théoriques mans on peut le
faire mais nous notre on va dire notre
mais c'est un détour à l'heure actuelle
a nommé aujourd'hui on l'a créée pour
faire que chaque citoyen s'investit
pleinement dans va dans dans la
politique publique qui le concerne la
lutte va t'elle justement est-ce que
vous pensez que la la ville c'est celle
où la géographie idéal justement pour
pour cette nouvelle forme de démocratie
ah oui toutes appelées cheveux d'abord
parce que c'est l'intérêt qui prime
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on voit
bien les habitants de plus en plus que
envie de et dans la vie locale et avec
la compagnie de qui on sent très très
bien cette présence plus forte des
habitants
d'abord parce qu'ils sont chez eux et
comme ils sont chez eux ils découvrent
c'est assez incroyable de dire ça mais
ils découvrent leur environnement le on
est on est en région parisienne sur le
mode du métro boulot dodo et finalement
sur le mode de la ville la ville dortoir
et la réalité c'est que maintenant en un
an
on a vu beaucoup plus de gens
s'intéresser à ce qui se passait autour
de chez eux à s'intéresser aux
finalement aux modalités de
fonctionnement de la ville et donc le
commencé à vouloir s'impliquer dans dans
la ville pas nécessairement sous forme d
lui parce que c'est souvent puis
complexe et tous les dix ans mais
s'impliquer de façon
plus plus présente sur tous les sujets
ont parlé c'est parler de d'urbanisme
oui sur l'organisme
on a besoin d'avoir des la concertation
du dialogue sur les transports on a
besoin d'avoir de concertation du
dialogue sur les cajas public le on
parle beaucoup de fermes et l'éclairage
public les pendant la nuit
là aussi ça fait partie de ces questions
il de plus en plus vont intéresser les
gens on est en train de mettre en place
sa tarification incitative des déchets
ce qui nous amène à parler beaucoup de
succès de cette question qui est qui est
très importante de la production de
déchets et à travers l'outil mutter on a
pu consulter un certain nombre de
personnes d amener à réfléchir sur leur
production de déchets et et à sortir de
cette paradigme sont extrêmement
bloquant pour pour le citoyen lambda qui
est à bas tout ça ça m'est donnée je ne
m'y intéresse pas et etc et l'intendance
suivra il met aujourd'hui on est plus il
faut qu'on arrive à changer cette cette
approche pour que tout le monde
comprenne que la gestion des déchets ça
fait partie de la vie citoyenne ça fait
partie de d'une vie publique qui s'est
fait et organisé structuré par les
collectivités
mais à laquelle chacun peut participer
par son action voyez c il ya une énorme
évolution
en tout cas moi je je je je la sens en
tant que mais il ya une énorme évolution
en un an de pandémie vert
ce que je pense être un progrès à savoir
beaucoup plus d'intérêt de du citoyen
sur le local et donc du coup
effectivement ce que des factions partir
du local ccl qui s'est créé une base une
base de dangy de s'impliquer dans vie de
participer et petit à petit derrière fo
furieux de la compréhension du système
du système politique actuel délicat la
répartition des compétences avec qui je
vais m'appliquer voyez on peut ensuite
aller vers vers les strates supérieures
et puis lorient justement alors votre
livre porte sur la démocratie
participative locale mais on voit naître
de tout c'est toutes ces commissions les
convention citoyenne sur le climat sur
les dunes sur la vaccination
là encore le cadre juridique est assez
floue les décisions prennent ces
conventions
alors politiquement on est peut-être
vous appliquez mais juridiquement il n'y
a pas d'obligation effectivement
juridiquement il n'y a pas d'obligation
est d'ailleurs mettre en place une
obligation ce serait contraire au fameux
principe général
on en parlait tout à l'heure après je
pense qu'il faut nuancer la différence
entre le caractère contraignant
juridiquement et puis l'engagement
politique parce que dès lors qu'une
personne et lui met en place un
dispositif participatif
ça envoie ils organiquement un message
selon lequel on est prêt à recevoir des
propositions et même des contestations
donc à ce moment là il est difficile de
ne pas tenir compte du tout de ce qui a
été dit mais je pense qu'au final que ce
qui est important pour résoudre un peu
cette contradiction apparente entre le
caractère juridiquement contraignant et
l'engagement politique c'est de
clarifier finalement le contrat qui est
passé entre les personnes élues et les
citoyennes et les citoyens c'est à dire
que les personnes élues qui met un sujet
en projet à la discussion identifie
clairement
les points sur lesquels ils sont prêts à
entendre un modifié à faire des
amendements au projet et les points sur
lesquels il n'y aura a priori pas de
changement possible pas de négociation
possible
je pense qu'à partir du moment où cela
est larry filles on arrive à un contrat
et tout le monde sait dans quoi il se
lance et on peut arriver à un résultat
productif et qui ne crée pas de
frustration
c'est vrai que généralement quand on
fait une convention citoyenne
le président de la république dis
toujours je prendrai toutes les mesures
que vous proposerez et puis après on en
regrette quand même quelques unes à
brioni
justement vous aviez a pas répondu à
cette question est ce que finalement
c'est une nouvelle forme de démocratie
et de ses civic tech là comme on les
appelle c'est une démocratie augmenté
par la part la technologie ou est ce que
c'est une création des nouvelles
technologies qu'est ce que vous entendez
par est-ce que est ce que au fond c'est
les nouvelles technologies qui nous
amène à réfléchir autre bon là la
démocratie à ok non je pense que il ya
dans l'histoire enfin énormément
d'exemples de 2,2 moment où l'on demande
de plus de démocratie sur française on a
eu pas les dangers dans le passé récent
je dirais qu'il ya goursaud de 3 moment
peut-être wef
ou plutôt deux grands moments on va dire
contre les années 60 70
et puis le basculement après la crise de
tout l'art dans laquelle c'est une vague
qui a commencé après la crise dans
laquelle on se trouve un corps moi j'ai
un vite de ce qui a été dit pourrait
prendre la d finale après même chose sur
laquelle dans la gamme ea était avait
parfaitement expliquer la différence en
3d loquace et j'ai envie de rajouter un
petit et un petit outil conceptuel pour
ceux qui nous écoutent
il y a
en cause une science politique quelque
chose qui appelle les chaînes bernstein
qui est en fait une chaîne qui avec sept
niveaux que je vais pas je veux pas dire
on va dire ça va au delà de la simple
information de citoyenne c'est à dire
les mines tout simplement font un effort
pour informer convoqué les citoyens pour
leur informer les informer de leur
dédiant tour etc jusqu'à la côte des
scissions un passant par la consultation
et donc par exemple cette expérience
magnifique
de mon point de vue de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat magnifique
pourquoi parce que d'un point de vue
délibératif je pense que c'est vraiment
réussi mais le grand défaut de cette de
cette expérience c'est que le niveau de
la côte décision est totalement absent
parce que justement comme vous l'avez
remarqué bas après le gouvernement oui
zbrush et es13 de joker et finalement
c'était je sais pas combien
et est ce qu'ils les choses qui ont été
retenus c'est parce que on ses limites
et c'est pour ça je veux conclure avec
ça c'est que le terme de participation
parfois ça fait ça fait tester des
personnes parce que il faut distinguer
moi j'aurais envie de dire entre en un
sens strict un centre plus vaste de
participation puisque si sir au sens
strict on en même temps la simple sûrs
consultation ou délibération bas
évidemment oui ok on peut demander
l'avis des citoyens est ce que rien
faire de saleh mais si on a en ce sens
ce plus les années énergie efforts de
participation alors à ces moments là il
faut avoir à la fois la délibération
mais aussi la démocratie directe les
deux choses vont ensemble et d'ailleurs
j'ai envie tenir les deux choses ne
doivent jamais être séparés parce que
l'une corrige l'autre en quelques sortes
est ce que par exemple le reste nous
attendons à ce que le temps le temps
mais c'est passionnant n'aura l'occasion
je pense de reprendre ce débat parce que
après tout le vieux rêve de la grecque
la détresse démocratie directe remise
grâce à la technologie dans nos sociétés
c'est un rêve qui peut exister
merci infiniment à tous les quatre merci
luc chatel merci stéphane b qu'un merci
fabrice diot défini et merci camille
morieux dont je rappelle le titre de
votre livre c'est le guide pratique de
la démocratie participe le participative
pardon locales etc berger levrault merci
infiniment
et à très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
paf merci à vous
[Musique]